[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to effective
machine learning with cloud CPUs I'm
delighted to see all of you here and I'd
like to send a special welcome to
everyone on the livestream or anyone
who's watching this as a recording later
I'm Zack stone I'm the product manager
for tensorflow and cloud GPUs on the
Google brain team and this talk is about
super computers for machine learning
that are built around Google's custom
chips called tensor processing units or
TP use we've had three generations of
tensor processing units including the
one on the bottom that sundar announced
in his keynote earlier this morning but
before I get into the details here I
just want to set the stage for a moment
and share a little bit of context about
why this matters there's been a
tremendous amount of machine learning
progress over the past several years as
you've already heard earlier today if
you look at the number of research
publications on archive which is an open
site for sharing papers the number of
papers published is growing faster than
Moore's Law and we're up to something
like 50 new machine learning papers
every day this is a tremendous rate of
innovation a lot of it's happening in
the open which is fantastic and it's
driving a lot of new applications and
real progress across a wide range of
fields as you can see here in just one
domain computer vision there's been a
tremendous increase in accuracy on this
imagenet benchmark challenge just over
the past few years rising from the
original breakthrough results with alex
net all the way to some of the more
recent machine learning models but these
accuracy trends come at a cost then I'll
tell you about in a minute first I want
to help you understand what those sort
of applications are about you've heard a
little bit about diabetic retinopathy
and also these new signals of heart
health that you can get in a completely
passive way just by taking a picture of
the back of the eye this is the kind of
real world application that's going to
help improve people's lives that's only
possible because of these cutting-edge
accurate powerful models in machine
learning you've also probably heard
about tracking illegal logging in the
rain forest by putting recycled
cellphones in tree
that can listen for sounds of chainsaws
or other activities and help people
protect rainforests in the central
Amazon now one thing that's really
changed even since I was in graduate
school is this unification across many
different application domains before it
might have been that the folks in
computer vision had one set of
techniques the folks in speech
recognition had a different set of
techniques and the folks doing machine
translation were doing yet a third set
of techniques to go from you know one
language to another but what we've been
seeing over the past few years is this
consolidation especially in deep
learning around these neural networks
that have similar components even if the
details of their structure are different
and these neural networks are now
achieving state-of-the-art results
across all these different tasks often
these results are at accuracies that we
don't know how to achieve any other way
so now as I mentioned earlier this has
come at a bit of a cost which is as
these models get more accurate they tend
to be larger trained on larger data sets
and that means that you need more
computation both to train the model on
the data set and then eventually to run
it what I'm showing here is this plot of
these image recognition models on image
net this time ranked with you know
accuracy on the vertical axis and then
the number of multiply ads which is sort
of a rough metric of computational costs
on the on the horizontal axis and as you
can see as you get to these higher and
higher accuracies you're actually
requiring larger and larger amounts of
computation so the solution to this
problem we believe is specialized
hardware for machine learning and that's
what's really driven us to develop these
multiple generations of tensor
processing units or TP use our first TP
use have been in our data center since
2015 and you've interacted with these
every time you've run a search their
rear ankle the last several hundred
links to choose the ten that they're
showing you they're a said they've been
essential part of Google photos and
speech recognition and many of Google's
large-scale applications that you use
every day last year we revealed our
second Jenner
raishin tensor processing units which
are now in public beta anyone can sign
up any GCP project can start a cloud cpu
and that you can follow the link g-code
slash cloud cpu to learn more these CPUs
aren't just for training an inference on
a single system though they're really
designed to be connected together into
these large-scale supercomputers that we
call TPU pods and later this year TPU
pods are coming to cloud as cloud CPU
pods here's a full pod of the
second-generation TP use on the screen
right now finally this morning you're
getting the first glimpse of our
third-generation TP use assembled into
an even larger TPU pod that delivers
more than a hundred petaflop sub compute
for a single machine learning problem so
I just want to emphasize that we are
committed to making relentless progress
in this domain this affects all of our
products it improves the lives of all of
our users and through the cloud we're
bringing these platforms to you so you
can train machine learning models and
run them faster and more
cost-effectively than ever before just a
few notes on performance you can see TPU
v1 with 92 tera ops only doing inference
then going to the cloud TPU which is 180
teraflops suddenly have floating-point
it's a lot easier to work with you don't
have to worry about quantization and
those are connected together into these
systems that as I mentioned before are
up to 11 and a half petaflop
and do training and inference either on
a single problem or you can slice them
into smaller pieces to do many different
problems at once just a year later now
we're making this leap from about eleven
and a half cut off lots to more than a
hundred that's more than eight X the
performance of a TPU v2 pod in this new
v3 system and that's a combination of an
entirely new chip wired together into an
even larger scale system so I hope the
reason that you're all here is because
you're interested in expanding the AI
frontier that's what really motivates us
when we're developing these platforms
and building applications on top of them
now I'd really like to focus on what you
can do right now with the cloud CPUs
that are available today and that really
starts with performance a lot of these
machine learning models can take days or
weeks to train it hasn't been uncommon
in the past for it to cost thousands of
dollars just to do one training run of
these machine learning models and we're
really interested in bringing down those
costs and making machine learning
acceleration much more widely available
but when we're talking about performance
it's important to be very specific about
what we mean because it's quite subtle
sometimes to compare one system to
another
first of all in all of our measurements
we try to focus on real-world data time
to accuracy and cost so let me tell you
what I mean when you're training a
machine learning model and you're
processing millions of images it's
convenient to look at how many samples a
second you're processing as a measure of
performance but those samples per second
numbers don't matter unless you
ultimately get where you need to go
reach the correct final accuracy and so
what we're really looking to do is met
yes measure how fast the wheels are
spinning on the car but also make sure
that the car gets to the right
destination and crosses the finish line
so it's very important whenever you're
considering building buying renting a
machine learning system to make sure
that you're asking about not only steps
per second or samples per second but
also the training accuracy and the total
time to accomplish the task that you
really have in mind we've also put in a
lot of energy to try and make sure that
all these ML benchmarks that we talked
about are reproducible the open source
so almost all the numbers that I'm about
to show you either you can reproduce
today by going to gto slash cloud GPU
and renting a cloud GPU or they'll be
open source soon and so you'll be able
to reproduce them on your own you don't
just have to take my word for it now
Stanford recently hosted a competition
called dawn bench I've got a screen shot
of the website here
Don bench is the first public benchmark
challenge that we've seen really measure
performance and accuracy together which
we think was great there is active
participation from many different
companies and individuals and research
groups and I'm happy to announce that
cloud GPUs and TPU pods did very well
across several of the categories so in
the imagenet training cost competition
we had the number one Don bench entry
with a model called amoeba net d now
this is a really interesting fusion of
some of the work that we've been doing
in research with these new hardware
platforms because amoeba net was an
architecture that was actually evolved
from scratch on TP use and then that
model not only if you train it longer
can get to state-of-the-art accuracy on
image net but it can hit the target that
Don bench set of 93% in just seven and a
half hours for under $50 this really
makes this kind of state-of-the-art
performance accessible to a much wider
audience than it's ever been before
now another model that you may have
heard of that's frequently benchmarked
is res net 50 and so I just wanted to
show a quick case study of ResNet 50
running with tensorflow 1.8 which is our
most recent version we also submitted
this to Don bench and it also reaches
this accuracy of 93% which is not this
is top-5 accuracy that's not easy to do
with res net it's easy to fall just a
little bit short and you have to be very
careful throughout the implementation to
achieve that high accuracy while
maintaining this incredible performance
of more than 30 to 50 images per second
now this took almost nine hours to Train
for $59 but if you want to go faster
part of the reason that we designed
these systems to be connected together
is just by changing the batch size of
the model no code changes no complicated
thinking about distributed systems we
can run the same thing on half of one of
these TPU pods to hit the same level of
accuracy in just 30 minutes so that's
nine hours down to 30 minutes and these
are the pods that are coming to cloud
later this year so you'll be able to run
results like this on your own or train
on other models with other datasets of
your own
and if you eliminate the checkpoint
overhead which dawn bench didn't
actually require us to measure that's
actually just twenty four minutes
so what I'd like to mention though is
the field is moving extremely fast so
just as an example the third place entry
for training constant on bench was from
a nonprofit organization called fast I
and that actually came in at $72 but it
included some really interesting ideas
that weren't well-known one was this
progressive scaling up of training
images that enabled the model to move
even faster in the earlier phases of
training when it's just starting to
figure out how to complete the task and
they also used a much more aggressive
learning rate schedule that hadn't been
widely used the nice thing about cloud
abuse it was easy for us to to make
these open changes in our own model on
cloud TPU
and unofficially rerun the experiment
and these two simple changes take our
resident 50 training cost from $59 down
to just 25 with today's on-demand
pricing that you can get on Google cloud
so there's an open source reference
implementation available we've built
this into our B float16 version of
resident 50 and we'll have more to say
about this soon but kudos to facile AI
for the great algorithmic algorithmic
improvements and I'm just delighted as a
researcher and practitioner and now
product manager that so much of this
progress is widely shared so you might
be wondering well what's the next
benchmark challenge Don Bench finished
recently where do we go next to to
compare these very different systems of
different sizes and scales and even
different model architectures against
one another if we need to make a
decision about what to do when you want
to accomplish a goal well one new
challenge that's been released recently
is ml purse you can learn more about it
at ml per org there are a bunch of
researchers from different top
universities and also many companies
coming together to try and define a new
next-generation benchmark it's even more
challenging than Don bench and covers
many more problem domains the first
deadline is going to be in July that
this group is you know open to new
collaborators and also planning to
iterate on the definition of the bench
mark to make sure that it really tracks
where the field is going so I think this
is gonna be really exciting later this
year and I encourage you to participate
and check it out
and as I've mentioned before I just want
to provide a little bit more information
about what you can do today with cloud
GPUs if you want to experience this kind
of performance we've got this set of
reference models I'll say more about
them in a minute but they're right there
on github slash tensorflow slash TPU and
we've also got great documentation on
the cloud TPU website with the link
below but you don't have to remember the
big links at the top just geoduck cloud
slash cloud CPU will take you where you
need to go so now I'd like to give you a
sense of what it's like hands-on to use
these cloud CPUs first of all one thing
that's a little different than other
accelerators is that they're network
attached so what that means is you can
choose a virtual machine of any size or
shape you can you know attach other
accelerators to it if you want it can be
large but you would generally start with
a very tiny VM because this is really
playing just a coordinating role you
know as few as four cores are often
enough because all the real
computational work is happening on the
cloud GPU the nice thing about this
setup is that cloud GPU can be a single
device or it can be a slice of one of
those pods you don't have to worry about
it all that's handled for you
furthermore you don't have to worry
about messing with drivers you can just
use these machine images that we provide
you program tensor that you program
these cloud to use with tensor flow now
attention flow is the most popular open
source framework for machine learning
one of the top projects on github and
it's just taken off since it was open
sourced in November of 2015 we're now up
to something like 13 million downloads
all around the world tensorflow supports
many different kinds of machine learning
and has many different components when
you're programming cloud GPUs today
you'll focus on layers estimators the TF
data fast input pipelines and then your
code will be transformed behind the
scenes by the excel a compiler to talk
to the TPU so estimators and layers
really provide these flexible high-level
deep learning abstractions for
tensorflow
that let you map a wide variety of
different models to TP use here's just a
quick code
sample of a convolutional neural network
and this is how you would write it with
layers and estimators or some code
elided what you can see here is that you
just have to make some minimal changes
to map this over to the TPU changes in
the optimizer and the estimator and
we're working over time to make these
changes smaller and smaller so that
it'll be really convenient for you to
take tensorflow code that runs on CPUs
or GPUs run it on TP use move back and
forth wherever you need to take your
code and train or run one important bit
of advice though that I'd like to just
emphasize over and over high-performance
computing is hard on any platform and
these accelerators are so fast that you
need to really put in a lot of energy to
make sure that the whole system is
balanced and that every part of it is
performing as well as it possibly can
we've done a tremendous amount of this
work for you with these reference models
that I'm about to show you that we've
got open source on github for example
here are four different categories of
very different applications that are so
either supported today or are about to
be open source for cloud CPU over in the
image recognition Colin which is maybe
best known we've got amoeba net and
ResNet 50 also bigger versions of it
inception v2 v3 v4 but we can also do
object detection with retina net which
is another one of these recent
state-of-the-art models and I'll say
more about that in a minute also if
you're interested in training a machine
learning model and then deploying it at
the edge on a phone or a robot or a
drone or in a vehicle or somewhere else
you might want to train a smaller model
with something like mobile net or
squeeze net and cloud TV you support
those as well but we're not limited to
just image recognition or object
detection GPUs can also do machine
translation and language modeling
sentiment analysis question answering
all with this state-of-the-art model
architecture called transformer that's
very powerful and flexible turns out a
version of transformer can also perform
fantastic speech recognition and we've
just recently open sourced an example of
speech recognition training on cloud
GPUs as part of the tensor 2 tensor
framework tell you more about that in a
minute
and finally for those of you who are
researchers out there and are at the
cutting edge where you're generating
images from scratch over in the image
generation category we've got the image
transformer and also DC Gann so we've
really got a huge range of applications
that are not only possible to make work
on the cloud CPU but they're working
today with open source code that you can
just download it's a really easy way to
get started so for those of you who
aren't as familiar with this domain
image classification is often taking
these small images like this one and
mapping that to a category like lion
whereas object detection is taking a
larger images and looking for many
different objects in many different
places in the image the cool thing about
our retina and implementation is it lets
you process quite large images 896 by
896 trains to a very interesting
accuracy on the cocoa dataset 37 average
precision in just six hours for $40
machine translation training on the WMT
data set gets to a blue score of 28
point six which is very close to the
state of the art again in just six point
two hours for forty-one dollars and
these results are you know changing all
the time as we continue to optimize the
platform the implementations and new
research comes out much of which at
Google is conducted on these CPUs now
language modeling you're trying to
predict the next word this is an
important component of applications like
smart reply and again you can take the
language modeling the LM 1 be the 1
billion word dataset and train to a
state-of-the-art perplexity of 28 in 74
hours for under 500 dollars and I've
mentioned tensor to tensor again below
that's this open source project built on
top of tensor flow that has some of the
latest and greatest results for all of
these sequence to sequence models for
speech recognition we've got this model
called era ASR transformer which is
training on liber speech again to a
really interesting word error rate this
is a fantastic way if you have a large
labeled speech data set to just train
your own near state-of-the-art speech
recognition models from scratch in
whatever language or accent you care
about and you can you can get to a
reasonable accuracy for under $100
finally question answering here with QA
met this
just the fast version that we use to win
the question-answering competition Ford
on bench but there's a Stanford
question-and-answer dataset that takes a
big chunk of text and then presents a
question about some facts that you can
infer from reading the text so this
machine learning model is actually
looking at this whole paragraph of
unstructured text reading the question
and then pinpointing the answer it's
really impressive it's really different
from image recognition and all this is
possible on this sort of flexible new
powerful platform for machine learning
oh I forgot this I was gonna tell you a
little bit more about image generation
so the metric here is actually bits per
dimension and lower is better state of
the art is around two point nine two
right now but under three is really good
and you can get under three on this
metric in 30 hours for under two hundred
dollars if you're interested in
exploring this state of the art cutting
edge image generation examples all those
images on the right were generated from
scratch just dreaming on the basis of a
training set using this image
transformer model so again why start
with a reference model instead of just
opening a code editor and starting from
scratch well these reference models are
high-performance they're open source
they're cutting edge often collecting
input from researchers all across
alphabet we continuously test them for
performance and accuracy which means
that you don't have to worry that these
some subtle change in tensor flow or
some other part of the stack might might
reduce the accuracy without you
realizing it you can get up and running
really quickly and then modify as needed
because you have the code it's yours on
your infrastructure and you can train
and run on your own data but you're
perfectly welcome to do it the hard way
we have lots of detailed technical
advice in our troubleshooting guide and
you know I'm not kidding that high
performance computing is hard and any
part of the system can become a
bottleneck but we totally encourage you
to to take the high level layers and
estimators api's and build new models
and let us know what works for you just
to give you a little bit of a sense of
what makes high performance computing so
tricky you know if you're training with
slower Hardware you might find that you
can overlap you're in
be processing with your training time
and so your accelerators are always
saturated but when the accelerators get
a lot faster what you find all of a
sudden is that you're bottle necked on
the input processing and your
accelerators are sitting idle and so
fortunately we've provided a bunch of
tools that are connected into tensor
board which is this great visualization
framework associated with tensor flow to
help you debug your performance
understand what's going on here I'm
showing the steps per second and the
loss but we actually have this very
detailed profiler that lets you go in
and get up by op statistics on what's
going on in your model and we even have
high-level recommendations I don't know
if you can read the read text but it's
telling you in this case your model is
not input bound so you should spend more
time on optimizing the step performance
you know in other cases it'll tell you
you're blocked on input don't bother
improving the speed of your model you
need a faster input pipeline and that's
where TF data can help so we're really
doing our best to prevent to present
these tools for experts and all this
documentation for experts but also to
make it really easy to get started with
these reference models across this huge
range of applications now those of you
who are used to training and running
machine learning models under your desk
you might wonder well why should I jump
to the cloud that seems like a different
platform how do I think about that the
nice thing about training in the cloud
is that you get access to all this
top-notch infrastructure where you can
mix and match the different components
you need like those custom VM shapes I
was telling you about earlier you can
scale up and down quickly you don't need
to order Hardware maybe build a machine
yourself wait for months sometimes for
hardware to arrive you can just sign on
today and scale up to hundreds of TP use
if you wish there's great security all
throughout Google Cloud Google is
state-of-the-art in security across the
entire platform for enterprises that
want cutting-edge of machine learning
hardware and you're really able to
reduce your capital expenditure with
this on demand pricing you're just
paying only for what you use you can
train one of these models for 50 bucks
and then turn the cloud tip you off and
you're not paying for it anymore which
is great so just a few words from
two of our customers for cloud CPUs 2
Sigma is a financial firm and lift this
is their self-driving vehicle team both
of them have had great experiences using
cloud CPUs to focus on building the
models instead of worrying about these
massive distributed clusters of other
hardware and taking these models that
used to train for 4 days in some cases
down to hours and you know with these
larger and larger pods we're really
trying to drive that 2 minutes so let's
go under the hood and talk in a little
bit more detail about what's going on in
the current generation of cloud TPU so
first of all the cloud CPU actually
includes a host with this accelerator
all behind the scenes connected via PCI
each cloud GPU device has these four
chips under the heat sinks here and I'm
going to zoom in on one of them if you
look at the cloud GPU chip layout you'll
see that it's broken down into two cores
that look like this
now these cores are really built around
this systolic array which is an old idea
but its newly relevant in this age of
machine learning when so many of the
computations really look like gigantic
matrix multiplies but we've also got a
vector unit and a scalar unit and in
this case it was you know eight
gigabytes of high bandwidth memory per
core and then there are two cores per
chip the new tp3 actually doubles the
memory per chip which is going to let
you train even larger and more capable
models focusing in on this matrix unit
this is saleh Caray one thing that's
really interesting about it is that
we're actually doing the multiplies with
a new floating-point format that's
called d float16 I'll say more about
that in a minute but it really gives us
this great performance for machine
learning without a meaningful cost and
accuracy we're still accumulating in
float32 though so most of you are
probably familiar with 32-bit
floating-point as you can see here the
orange mantissa bits are all devoted to
measuring these fine differences between
numbers which is really important if
you're doing high performance computing
detailed simulations that kind of thing
but in machine learning it turns out
that the range is much more important
and these machine learning models are
not super sensitive to these fine
differences by an
so the I Triple E standard for a 16-bit
floating-point truncates boasts the
exponent and the mantissa as you can see
here and it really cuts down the range
of numbers that you can express one
thing that we find we're finding with
tensorflow is if you're training with
half precision I Triple E like this you
really have to pay attention and you
need to get an expert involved on a
model by model basis to make sure that
all of your numbers stay in the right
range and don't overflow and those
techniques are difficult to apply in
general across a wide range of models
with B flat 16 though what we've done
instead is saved a lot more bits for the
exponent which preserves the range and
so in many models this is a drop-in
replacement for float 32 and it's
supported seamlessly by our cloud CPU
hardware so those resident 50 results
that I was talking about earlier those
were achieved with be float 16 and as
you notice we're still achieving that
high you know 76 percent top 1 or 93
percent top 5 accuracy with a minimum of
effort and special casing on a model by
model basis so here I'll show you a
brief animation of the systolic array in
this slide it's only 3 by 3 but imagine
this is 128 by 128 to get a sense of how
different this is from an ordinary
central processing unit and how much
parallelism there is which is where
we're getting this fantastic performance
so here you have data streaming in and
what's happening as the systolic or a
sort of beats on every step is you're
getting great reuse of these
intermediate results as the data is
flowing through the systolic array and
generating the outputs so this is super
high throughput for matrix
multiplications and it's tightly
integrated with the other parts of our
TPU that support all these other custom
operations and and our excellent
compiler also does a great job of taking
high level mathematical expressions and
then mapping them down into this
coordinated dance of low level
operations that gives this tremendous
amount of speed so where do we go from
here well first of all I really want to
emphasize something I haven't called out
explicitly about scaling up I think the
days of single systems are irrelevant
there Oh
her because what you care about
ultimately is how fast you get to your
result right and so what we're trying to
do with these cloud CPUs and making them
widely available in the cloud is giving
you just a dial that you can turn where
you do your prototyping on an
inexpensive single device and then you
increase the batch size without doing
any other code changes and suddenly your
training time is going down from hours
to minutes and so I'll show you two you
know real measurements from our TPU
systems in-house here to give you a
sense of how that's possible first of
all what I'm demonstrating here if you
look at these TPU devices so the
second-generation TPU pod has 64 of
these boards in it and you can see
linear scaling of images per second up
and to the right here and as you know
remember if you hear images per second
it's like but wait what about the
accuracy you can check our Don bench
results that 30 minute result also
confirms that we can still get the high
accuracy with this scale out but what
you can see is that our interconnect in
this pot is so fast that you don't have
to struggle the way you would with
mixing and matching Hardware on your own
whether on-premise or in the cloud you
can just turn this dial with no code
changes and benefit from this superfast
proprietary Network but there's a more
subtle point here that's a mathematical
issue which is until recently it hasn't
been clear how to take these machine
learning models and increase the batch
size which is how many of these images
you're processing simultaneously sort of
in each step while you're training
there's been a huge amount of research
energy on this recently and there's been
a lot of breakthroughs where we're now
able to train effectively on much larger
batch sizes from ever before that's
great news for scaling up with these TPU
pods let me help you interpret this
graph
what you see on the horizontal axis here
is time and then what you see on the
vertical axis is accuracy and so you
might imagine you know your first
implementation on your cloud keep you
that you're renting today gets to let's
say 76 percent accuracy on ResNet 50 and
that takes a certain amount of time
that's that orange curve
out there but with no code changes just
by changing the batch size in the right
way with the models that we've already
open-sourced you can pull that time in
as you're using larger and larger
sections of the pod you know until you
get down to these these you know 30
minute results or possibly even better
so we think this is an extremely
promising research direction and we're
doing our best in all these reference
implementations to make sure that it's
immediately accessible to you so once
these pods become more widely available
in cloud then you'll be able to just
transparently benefit from this large
batch training I'd love to live in a
world where you can use an exaflop for a
minute and then let it go and think for
a while while somebody else is using it
and just swap back and forth
now here's another view of the full TPU
V 3 pod that sundar showed you this
morning and we are doing everything that
we can to push the boundaries of
performance and that's what's really led
us to liquid cool this pod in comparison
to everything that we've done previously
that's air cooled if you want a cool
close up view here it is a close-up view
of just one of the boards in that pod it
looks sort of like this and you can see
the tubing you know now those plates are
on each one of these next generation TPU
b3 processors so we're gonna go to the
largest batch sizes we can you know
we're publishing all this research that
we're doing we're open sourcing as much
of it as we can on these clouds you few
platforms that you can access today and
so we're really excited in going with
you into this exciting AI frontier you
can get started right now with these
high-performance reference models and
tutorials and please reach out to us let
us know we'd be really interested in
hearing your feedback on the cloud GPU
platform of today we'd love to know
where you'd like it to go we hope you
enjoy trying all these different
applications across image recognition
and speech recognition and image
generation and machine translation and
I'd be happy to take some of your
questions offline after the talk so
thank you very much for listening I've
included some links here thanks again
[Music]